swerving swallows deftly maneuvering
moss this is what drones are made of
scientists have turned to mother
nature's most adept aerial acrobats
birds bees bats and other animals to
inspire their designs for self-directed
drones with the right tweaks these
drones have the potential to fight
forest fires spot poachers and catch
polluters but first the unmanned
machines have to be able to maneuver in
tight spaces and think for themselves
and that's where nature's original high
flyers come in swallows for example
swoop and swerve and patterns that would
knock top fighter pilots unconscious
tracing the birds paths along with those
of other species scientists are learning
how to make their drones more nimble
recently a team from MIT created an
artificial pilot that could control a
bird-like drone to twist through
different sets goalposts to zoom their
vertical goalposts the drone knife
sideways and just slips by it can do
this and then quickly right itself to
shoot through a set of horizontal
goalposts to to navigate obstacles a bit
more complex than lab setups team
created an autopilot system for the
drone to track how close it got to
things like trees and buildings
ultimately the goal is to create an
on-board computer that can tell the drug
to pitch and roll out of harm's way
that same team also created a drone that
can hit the brakes and safely park
itself on a thin wire if a fixed-wing
aircraft hit the brakes it would stall
and crash but by creating a computer
algorithm to read airflow over the wings
and adjust its tail flaps the drone sets
itself down safely without a scratch of
course there's more work to be done
scientists want to make their drones as
acrobatic as possible and that means
intense scrutiny of all kinds of animals
liars